we want to meet now an artist who is an
expert in
this field joep lyrsen is the 2020
laureate of the alia prize for cultural
values
as a cultural historian at the
university of amsterdam
he has made it his mission to study how
european culture
can come to terms with national
sentiments
and i have the pleasure now to talk to
joe blairson
i'm connected with him digitally good
morning thanks for joining us hello
there
let's start with a question which is
really difficult but maybe you can
answer it quickly what do you think
is the defining element of the european
identity
yeah well um the answer is
um if there has to be a short answer
complexity
and i mean that in two ways there's
first of all the complexity of a long
history
it goes back to many different periods
all the way from classical antiquity to
the present day
and all these periods have left
different self images different
identities in our rearview mirror and
that goes from the rule of law
to the spirit of enterprise to the
memories of tyranny
and oppression and that leads to the
second point of complexity
the european identity is terribly you
know
subject to moral contradictions on the
one hand there is
that set of memories which leads to
supremacism pride eurocentrism
and on the other hand there's a great
degree of remorse and trauma like what
have we done
so and all this is at the same time so
to be european means to
live with mixed feelings that's true
what are the scientific challenges so
when you research
a topic like european culture
right uh yeah they're fairly substantial
uh to begin with nobody knows what
culture is ev
any more than what european identity is
it's a very fuzzy undifferentiated idea
it can go from ingrained habits and
lifestyles to
arts and sciences and it's very
difficult to operationalize as a
scientific question so i
people tend to reduce culture to the
underlying
input factors rather than to analyze
what it actually does
and what it does to us so i've been
trying to do big fuzzy data
with computer aided analyses
and secondly there's another problem
people tend to see culture as being
specific to a given nation
we have a national tunnel vision and we
tend to filter out what's
entangled transnationally and how
culture crosses borders and that makes
it very different to study culture
at the european level computers can help
you very briefly we all have a lot of
stereotypes in our minds
but how important are stereotypes though
in contemporary culture
much more important than we think i
would say they are
our cultural subconscious we think we
are innovative modern
you know forward moving but in so many
respects we keep on falling back on the
narratives the myths the explanations
that we heard in our childhood
from the past and we recycle these
images these memories these myths
think of a netflix series like barbara
or you know
the stories of the past that keep on
being recycled
okay thank you so much we are looking
forward to learn more in your event
during the summit thanks a lot